so I have some really interesting
information on what happens when your
body starts drying out I'm talking about
dry skin like dry hands let's say your
hands are getting dry and wrinkly or
let's say for example you have a dry
mouth or dry eyes what is behind this
dryness okay there's multiple causes
let's start with your skin so if people
have dry skin they usually take some
type of moisturizer to counter it but
what happens after about five or six
minutes is all of a sudden it's dry
again so they need this moisturizer over
and over and over you have to realize
that whatever's in that cream goes
directly into your skin into your
bloodstream into the liver and other
organs so if there's petroleum if
there's chemicals it's going right
inside your body and unfortunately a lot
of these moisturizer creams actually end
up drying you out because they have
certain things in them like alcohol
either consumption of alcohol or in a
cream can make you dry from the inside
out then we have petroleum products
right so you have to start reading the
label on your creams and avoid anything
with petroleum medication psych drugs
high blood pressure medication there's
actually over 500 drugs that have as
their symptom dry skin if you're a
diabetic you'll have a tendency to have
more dry skin mineral oil which is not
good to be either in your products
topically or taking internally an
autoimmune condition Lupus can also
affect your eyes mouth but definitely
dry skin and dry hair
um if you have City Water okay and you
don't have spring water and you don't
have a filter you get fluoride you get
chlorine all sorts of chemicals that
will just completely dry your skin out
not to mention drinking tap water can
make you dry from the inside out so you
have to realize that because you have
dry skin it's not necessarily something
you're putting on topically it could be
something you're taking internally now
the other elephant in the room is soap
and excessively washing your hands or
using some type of detergent
detergents pull out oils okay so you're
going to basically pull out all these
really important oils in your skin like
vitamin A vitamin D vitamin E and many
other oils that are not vitamins but are
essential fats that you need to keep
your skin of a certain moisture now if
you have gut issues okay that can
actually create all sorts of skin
problems one being dry skin so if you
have dry skin and you have a cup problem
I would start taking a probiotic and you
probably will see changes within weeks
now the liver is a really important
organ in relationship to your skin your
skin is a good reflection of what's
going on in your liver if you have liver
cirrhosis inflammation in the liver if
you have a fatty liver you're going to
have some skin issues and dry skin is
definitely one of them because think
about what your liver does with fat
soluble vitamins I mean it's a key organ
to help you store some of these fat
soluble vitamins like vitamin A for
example that relates to the eyes so
let's shift from the skin to dry eyes if
your eyes are dry the most likely cause
is a vitamin A deficiency I remember I
used to have dry eyes really bad
um to the point where my eyes were
sticky it affected my vision and one
time I opened my eyes and it tore my
cornea so I had a long history of
problems with my eyes especially being
dry and of course I had a gallbladder
problem for 20 years had no clues my
gallbladder gallbladder problems refer
pain to the right shoulder right and
when you have a gallbladder problem many
times you're deficient in bile and you
can't absorb the fat soluble vitamins
and vitamin A is one big one and so you
may notice this either in dry eyes or a
lack of vision in the evening when it's
dark when you're trying to drive also
vegans who don't consume saturated fats
tend to have a problem with their bile
and gallbladder issues because the bile
is triggered by saturated fats so if you
don't trigger the production of bile you
could end up with a deficiency of a bile
and also a deficiency of these fat
soluble vitamins which by the way since
we're on the topic of vitamin A let me
just talk about this this is a very
important point you have what people
think is vitamin A which is
beta-carotene because they call it
vitamin A but beta-carotene is only a
precursor or vitamin A so when you see
this you know orange or yellow carrot or
yams or other plants that is loaded with
beta-carotene egg yolks also have
beta-carotene by plant sources don't
have the active form of what
beta-carotene turns into which is
retinol so what you have to realize is
that even though they call beta-carotene
vitamin A it's really not the active
form it has to be converted and the
percent of conversion is really small
it's like three percent so don't expect
to get your retinal active form of
vitamin A from Plants it's just it's
nearly impossible as a side note egg
yolks also have beta-carotene as well as
retinol so they have both but the point
is you need retinol to prevent dry eyes
the best source of retinol which is the
active form of vitamin A it's liver
egg yolks and cod liver oil so typically
you can have dry eyes from either
something lacking in your diet or
usually it's a gallbladder problem also
realize that your microbes make a
secondary type of bile salt
and you could be deficient in those
microbes and that could be the reason
why you're not pulling this vitamin A
into your eyes the next point I want to
bring up about dryness in your body and
I'm talking about skin dry mouth and dry
eyes
has something to do with menopause let's
say you are going through menopause and
you have this hormonal shift typically
what happens you have a decrease of
estrogen but you have a a more
significant decrease in progesterone so
we have this major drop in progesterone
and this drop in estrogen that's not as
low so the ratio is really low
progesterone to high estrogen but it's
really not too high but just the ratios
are off these ratios can greatly affect
your skin they can affect your collagen
but they will usually make your skin
very very dry this is why women after
menopause notice that their skin is so
dry and they start using all these
creams and it doesn't seem to work and
the skin sometimes looks wrinkly on
their hands or their face so this is
what I recommend you do you could take a
progesterone cream and put into your
skin and see good results but I think
another thing you may want to try first
would be to take a DHEA product okay
it's a natural product you can take
which is kind of like a building block
for these hormones to tend to boost them
up it's kind of like the raw material to
build up more progesterone as well as
estrogen and other hormones too like
cortisol and testosterone things like
that so if you were to take that as a
supplement not a lot you just need a
little bit because if you take too much
you know you can actually raise hormones
higher than it should be the last area I
want to talk about is dry mouth okay
what can cause dry mouth more
specifically than what I already talked
about if your body is producing less
than 0.1 milliliters of saliva per
minute you will fit in the category of a
deficiency of saliva which is going to
cause dry mouth now here's one little
side note your saliva makes certain
things like sodium bicarbonate which is
baking soda to help buffer the acids in
your mouth and so there's a lot of
benefits to having enough so lava that
can help prevent cavities to help
prevent tartar that I did a whole video
on in the past
antibiotics okay can create a dry mouth
antibiotics can increase your risk of
getting candida which can also give you
a dry mouth and then if you're consuming
sugar that feeds the candida it just
will never go away so if you have
candida you absolutely positively need
to get rid of all sugar in the diet and
that will greatly help you all right
next one is stress stress can really
alter the salivary glands I know in the
past when I had a great fear of public
speaking and I had to speak wow my mouth
got so dry I couldn't even talk so
there's a fact of being in the flight or
fight mechanism and having this stress
or high levels of cortisol and
adrenaline in relationship to what that
does to your salivary glands and
creating dry mouth so supporting the
adrenal glands and overcoming this fear
of public speaking could be very
beneficial all right there's also a
situation if you had
kobit for example okay or even taking
certain vaccines that relate to that
virus can give you dry mouth as a side
effect and the mechanism usually
involves a deficiency of zinc so without
enough zinc you could have dry amount as
well all right we already talked about
drinking alcohol that can dry you out I
mean think about when you wake up in the
morning you're completely dehydrated you
might have a headache and you're
definitely going to have a dry mouth
going to the dentist and getting a
fluoride treatment because you want to
make your teeth whiter or having extra
fluoride in your toothpaste can also
affect the microbiome in your mouth and
create dry mouth the last thing which is
probably the most important thing is
your diet if you are on a high carb diet
you're going to notice you're going to
have more of a dry mouth so of course
the thing to do is to go low carb all
right so I've given you a lot of things
to think with whether you have dry eyes
a dry mouth or dry skin and I'm going to
put some links down below to more
specific videos if you have a dry mouth
or dry eyes but as far as a remedy for
dry skin I have a new combination that I
would highly recommend you try it's
combining two things lanolin with
vitamin E oil what is lanolin that is a
natural substance that sheep produce
that keep their skin and wool nice and
protected and you can get this as a
natural product okay then you can put on
your skin it works great for dry skin
now I will say there's a a little bit of
a scent to it that you may not like but
it's not that bad but it's very very
natural if you get the natural one
without the detergents the deodorizers
the alcohol that they normally put in
there so just get something very very
natural and then put a little bit in a
dish with a couple drops of natural
vitamin E oil mix it up good and rub
that into your hands
in other parts of your body and you're
going to notice a great moisturizer
effect especially in the winter and I
think you'll really like the solution
now if you haven't seen my other video
on what to do for dry hands I put that
video up right here it's been very
popular check it out